un
derby a remporté ce dimanche 13 février
versailles recevait où il y au stade mob
auront pour un match en retard qui
comptait pour la dixième journée de
fédérale 3 plus solide versailles
déroule devant son public en première
période avec trois essais en poche le
score à la pause 29 à 10 de 30 ans quand
on était dans nos cinq mètres on a tenté
d'aider des jet skis où il n'y avait pas
il n'y avait pas lieu de faire ces
gestes-là qui nous ont fait nous
retrouver dans l'antre entre les perches
et voilà franchement leur entrée elle
était parfaite et une certaine solidité
défensive de leur part aussi parce
qu'ils n'ont jamais rompu on fait une
très grosse entame ce qui nous permet
vraiment de bien rentrer dans le match
qui permet un petit peu de nous
installer dans cette danse est parti on
a pris l'ascendant sur tous les duels
sur toutes les phases de conquête et de
rock donc on fait une très bonne entame
une très bonne première mi temps en
seconde période où il revient dans le
match et bouscule les versets y est mais
les joueurs de la cité royale tiennent
bon score final 36 à 25 le bonus
offensif s'envole pour le rcv
c'est un parfait saint parfait mais on
va s'enfoncer parce que en manque de
rythme depuis le début l'année ça fait
que deuxième match qu'on dispute
actuellement et voilà du coup ça se
ressent notre force que des blessés dans
les trois dernières minutes et puis la
cie la claque que l'adversaire revient
aujourd'hui donc c'est dommage falloir
qu'on repose là-dessus ça va au delà de
notre force avec ce résultat le club de
verser euros prend la tête de la poule
une du championnat de fédérale 3 wii est
à la quatrième place